salut à vous peuple d internet
aujourd'hui nous allons faire une vidéo
sur les émotions mais via le prisme de
la comédie de la galéjade des
saltimbanques pour ça j'ai demandé à
quelqu'un que vous avez déjà vu sur la
chaîne de venir nous expliquer un petit
peu parce que cette personne là a fait
le conservatoire oui monsieur oui madame
il s'agit de céline h aujourd'hui on
tourne en public
on a même des rires enregistrés ça
marche on va faire des situations que
vous m'avez donné sur facebook le 13
septembre pour être précis les 800
réponses et on va devoir les jouets avec
cyril n'a rien à perdre et rien à gagner
on n'est pas chirac on n'est pas chez mc
fly et carlito dépenser de l'argent pour
acheter des balançoires dimitri de la
chaîne filtre isr recherches je peux
vous dire que je connais depuis très
longtemps et cyril deux super connard
d'augmenter dans un premier temps
monsieur cyril y est ce vous qui avez
l'habitude de jouer carrément je suis
acteur on n'était pas d'accord quand tu
fais quand tu fais du roleplay
ouais c'est vrai tu joue beaucoup dans
cette vidéo je crois que même au gaming
c'est celui que je vois le plus incarner
les gens tu veux merci pour cet échange
une pression donc à ce que je vais vous
proposer ça va être quelque chose de
très ça c'est des choses qu'on qu'on
pratique notamment dans l'est dans les
cours de théâtre
je vous proposais de jeu une fratrie la
contextualiser une situation de manière
ça avec une émotion
moi je sais faire à plateau caillou
valoir allez on va voir la colère ok sur
une phrase part sur une situation de jeu
prépare un boeuf bourguignon
je prépare un peu bourdillon j'ai pas le
temps d'accord du désespoir
je prépare un boeuf bourguignon je peux
rester avec moi c'est dur c'est un bon
boeuf bourguignon de tout mis dedans
s'il te plaît c'est mon meilleur pote
bourguignon est sûre marièrent et eurent
beaucoup d'enfants
je vous fais trop rire
l'émerveillement je prépare un boeuf
bourguignon
c'est ce qu'on appelle un petit des
merveilles ouais bien je me colle à
l'est fabien olicard puisque c'est
peut-être un peu compliqué pour toi je
te propose de jouer je je prépare un
boeuf bourguignon avec la pudeur à
l'ehpad à l'ehpad massé cette phrase
kuder la pudeur la pudeur la pudeur
philosophie sachs jugeant comme on dit
non à la fin de plusieurs c'est ce que
tu ressens là parce que tu n'oses pas tu
n'oses pas soit pudeur soin de soi
carottes soit possible je prépare un
boeuf bourguignon avec le dégoût je je
je prépare un boeuf bourguignon
maintenant on est d'abord que j'explique
away que nous on veut bien voir la
portée flamme quand même je risque le
renvoi en syrie
nous nous sommes intéressés à avoir si
avant de donner des conseils tu es à
cette légitimité en juger tout ça
qu'est-ce que tu ne donnes pas bien fait
est-ce qu'on va sur un boeuf bourguignon
reste chanteuse pour dire quelle émotion
lui demande
moi je la tristesse la tristesse moi je
choisis quand même la pudeur peut voir
la pudeur aussi je commence pas
tristesse honneur aux assistés bien
actors studio
en fait en fait chaud
pas
voilà la meuf qui pleurent souvent et
donc la pudeur la pudeur
c'est vrai que la pudeur c'est pas c'est
pas c'est pas évident je prépare un un
boeuf bourguignon et je ne veux pas
qu'un jeu si vous me le permettez bien
sûr c'est pas ça et je sais que c'est
mon idée et j'avoue que c'est pas simple
la pudeur on va l'était il ya plusieurs
courants canton quand on démarre dans
l'acting ya eu la fameuse école brecht
en parler maintenant sur twitter qui en
gros un très très gros évoqué en fait
plus se mettait plus l'accent sur
finalement le message à faire passer
plus que sur la crédibilité du
personnage et puis il ya eu une école
d'acteurs si dieu voilà mr albert
d'aller aux issues de style sur ce style
là c'est les courants font face qui wish
bien connu exactement en référence et là
on part sur ce qu'a dit tout à l'heure
cyril sur un procédé de ressenti
émotionnel
donc pour être le plus sincère le plus
crédible il faut essayer de retrouver
des sentiments qu'on a soi même vécu
donc si tu veux jouer la tristesse le
mieux c'est en effet de ceux de se
remettre dans cette situation dans ce
contexte pour retrouver un peu de vérité
puisque puisqu'elle sera alimenté par de
la part des des vrais des vrais
sentiments sincères mais ça se laisser
submerger du bois dans la tristesse que
moi si je veux faire remonter un
souvenir qui met dans l'état où tu étais
là tu as l'air pour tomber dans l'union
pour reprendre la main après bah c'est
pour ça que c'est ça s'apprend pas
tomber ensemble audience et dimitri sera
notre notre juste main plutôt voix basse
comme bien aimé e tu seras le hasard par
ta main ce petit
j'ai un téléphone où il ya toutes les
800 propositions que vous avez fait sur
le facebook juste ici évidemment
facebook ou qu'elle vous aviez accès si
vous me suivez sur facebook
les mises en situations proposées par
des abonnés avec une couche de
l'improvisation de fait mais avec un
état émotionnel donné ok ok donc on peut
improviser un peu abbas et c'est bien
voilà créé sur les voisins ok très bien
on appartient à notre voisin c'est que
c'est qui qui la donne est comme ça on
va lancer allison allison engueulade
entre voisins quoi crise aux lèvres
hockey puisque c'est entre voisins je
vais quand même donné deux émotions
différentes puissant 4 que ça puisse
avoir un petit peu de là donc on va voir
quelqu'un de timide et quelqu'un qui est
réellement père mère choisit sa
perversion away niveau on ressent de
cette inversion donc fait un petit peu
de bruit le soir avec votre femme jeudi
je suis désolé de si je vous écoute pas
ou que sa vie personnelle
normal ça peut arriver d'entendre et et
ça ça vous fait quoi quand c'est un
temps des noms moi c'est pas pour vous
déranger jeu voici ce que vous nous
déranger jamais faux faux faux faux
venir frapper pendant dire matière à moi
d'accord merci parce que des fois c'est
un peu mou ben moi si j'aime bien
tranquille mais venez nous parler quand
on fait du bruit voyons venez comme vous
êtes on va pas se prendre la tête c'est
le soir vous dormez avec quoi d'ailleurs
avec avec votre lit avec rien du tout
sinon non mais non faut dormir avec eux
rien
le couple est parti sur une paire d'as
ion sexuelle écoute et on l'apprécié je
ne sais pas sur quoi tu as pu de reposer
pour avoir une forme de sincérité là
dessus plutôt les filles ou un truc que
je vis en ce moment autour des affaires
justement de 2,2 d'inversion comme les
balances ton port etc
on vas tu vois ce que vient alors que
les situations qu'on nous a décrit je me
suis appuyé là dessus ben ça c'est une
bonne idée c'est à dire qu'on est pas si
tu doit interpréter un personnage même
si tu l'as jamais vécu parce que on
n'est pas forcément censé avoir tout
vécu surtout sur des choses un peu un
peu compliqué auquel classe et l'impro
donc évidemment il n'y a pas de travail
ne s'est pas assez assez nourris moi je
suis reposé beaucoup sur les toques qui
sont assez connus de voilà toujours
soutient pleinement quelques trucs comme
ça et puis les gens aussi que je connais
parfois que disent oui à toutes celles
qui sont assez timides et qu'il sera
assez réservés ouais donc là plutôt sur
ça et donc c'est tout bête mais c'est
vrai que tout de suite on voit que dans
le corps il ya des différences c'est à
dire que celui qu'a lequel tient là
gallas en hausse avance ne s'avance ça
se voit il est il est comme ça il a une
espèce de postures un peu déjà un peu
dominante et le timide quand tu doit
l'interpréter à comme tu le dis tout de
suite pris le réflexe de exactement
voilà et bah ça c'est trop longue liste
est c'est clément qui propose de lever
le matin et bien bonjour à sa famille
dont on pourrait imaginer
on veut on peut on peut et donc on va
partir sur civil tué une mère ouais
ouais ouais c'est pas facile à faire
cette pièce ne pas tomber dans quelque
chose de trop trop gaguesque natoye
fabien olicard tu seras adolescent un
peu chiant attention je suis tel genre
demeurent à ouidah pas d'émotions permet
non c'est une mère fervente aimante et
vigilants vis-à-vis de son enfant ouais
bon jour du matin aux familles action et
s'il ne parle pas comme ça des matin je
me réveille qui me parle pas comme ça
c'est chiant comme ça on se réveille
jean marie magnet excuse pas c'était
quelque chose j'ai faim je te faire
quelque chose tu veux quoi mais je te
faire des petites cracotte à la
confiture tu le secteur mettant côte à
la confiture non menacent toujours les
mêmes marchés qua non du choco welch est
de faire un petit show qu ou pas ça va
tu fais pas aujourd'hui je réfléchis un
petit peu peut-être tes devoirs tu as
fait tes devoirs il faut faire tes
devoirs fabien tu sais très bien les
notes c'est pas encore ça il faut
vraiment qu'on essaie d'améliorer un
petit peu d'accord donc juste prenez un
second fabien je ne te parle fondé
l'école c'est important d'accord c'est
pour toi moi je suis pas d'accord je
vais pas venir embêter c'est pour toi
mais tu avais le monde
oui tu as eu ton bac mais tulard passé
trois fois ton bac tu ferais bien un
dimitri lui il a passé la première fois
qu'est ce qui va se passer après c'est
pour toi à fabien s'écoula mois
s'écoulent bah oui c'est pour toi moi ma
vie elle a été faite un g pas c'est pour
toi tu es bien réussi bah oui moi je
m'adapte
pourquoi tu dis ça moi je me donne à
temps mais j'ai trop envie d'avoir la
même pique toile et même journée moi
j'ai tout donné dans trois jours les
mêmes et toi comme c'est simple mais
j'ai abordé toujours parfois que j'ai
même pas demandé à naître
donc vous n'avez pas demandé à ce qu'on
parle ce matin
il va vite et sur les voies sont
annoncées des mois séparent du net
et ben oui là où on a vu une différence
peut-être que vous constaterez quand
vous regardez la vidéo c'est que les
premières secondes sais pas si tu es
d'accord sa flotte un petit peu c'est
normal c'est en amont et après il ya un
vrai truc qui se passe en termes de
qualité mais parce que c'est que la mère
elle est toujours dans son acte par
rapport à son regard bon ça c'est ça
c'est ça c'est vrai c'est à dire qu'elle
le regarde
ll le fixe elle est vraiment et lui
détourne le regard tout le temps
pourquoi tu nous fais pas voir
actionnaires dimitri quelle est la
situation s'il voulait le reste très
classique c'est bien elle qui propose un
entretien dans gauche je souhaite avoir
un recruteur dépressif et donc quelqu'un
qui vient incessant aux vêtements mais
qui dans lequel on le dit celui qui
place le mot boeuf bourguignon la gagne
rien même phrase je tiens de super
motivé ce tir et j'aimerais beaucoup
qu'elle poste voulait bien celui que
vous aviez proposé c'est à dire je ne
sais plus et plus bas sur notre goût
sinon je crois que recruteur quoi ouais
il ya quelqu'un aussi divers et parfois
bien sûr bien sûr tout avoué ben je suis
censé faire le ménage en fait d'accord
ça me motive à te marrer ça va vous oui
pas facile forcément pour tout le monde
des mâles qui tourne un peu mal un jour
bourguignonne hommes le passage des
fruits bail à nome derrière les hackers
qui baladent sur ok et vous ce que vous
pouvez vous amuser à faire en même temps
c'est de regarder nos visages moi je le
ferai au montage veut regarder un peu
voir est-ce que spontanément on a des
micro-expressions réel qui parce qu'on
essaye de jouer la comédie
on vous qu'on verra ça et si ça vous dit
je ferai un débrief de cette vidéo sur
une autre vidéo ça peut être intéressant
avec des zooms des trucs des machins
merci dimitri des immigrés the run sans
toi ça n'aurait pas été possible
merci master of silver konan alors si
vous avez les liens de ces trois chaînes
dans la description juste ici merci
beaucoup à venez vous mettez des pouces
en l'air amusé vous aimez vous ciao
[Musique]